[Musique]
vous ne serais pas légitime
ce sont des actions de l'action
d'activistes précis comme qui bloque
telle ou tel activité économique
l'entendre paralyser le pays ça c'est
pas la foule c'est un véritable problème
pour la mise en application de la loi
sur le fond je crois qu'on peut dire moi
j'ai trouvé très convaincant l'analyse
sur à la fois la réforme je trouve pour
une fois enfin on a eu une défense et
illustration des raisons de la réforme
rapides mais très pertinente c'est celle
que je que je porte en moi depuis des
mois sans arriver à la faire passer au
niveau c'est-à-dire que la réforme est
nécessaire parce que nous sommes engagés
dans une situation nationale où nous
devons effectivement augmenter
massivement notre capacité notre de
production et de travail ça fait deux
mois qu'on que la majorité répète ça pas
du tout elle a dit que c'était injuste
elle a dit non non elle n'a pas elle n'a
pas le évident a fait un discours dans
ce sens au mois de juillet puis on a
parlé de tout à fait autre chose on
s'est raccroché sur des histoires de
carrière long qui à mon avis n'étaient
pas dans le sujet sur le problème de la
justice non le véritable problème
c'était l'équilibre démographique
l'équilibre de la balance commerciale
qui veut dire que nous consommons plus
que nous ne produisons l'équilibre
budgétaire déficit budgétaire qui veut
dire que les grandes aspirations des
Français en matière d'école en matière
d'hôpital en matière de transition
climatique en matière également de force
militaires ne peuvent pas être traités
si nous n'augmentons pas notre capacité
globale de production ça passe donc la
réforme des retraites elle est faite
pour payer l'école les hôpitaux
pas payer l'école ça c'est vous vous
rentrez dans le raccourci qui a été
celui que je comprend très bien des
Français qui dit on va prendre notre
fric et on va le mettre ailleurs pas du
tout simplement il fallait il faut
augmenter la du gâteau il faut augmenter
ce que les Français produisent on ne
s'en sortira pas autrement c'est un
raccourci qui a fait le gouvernement
je crois avoir dit un instant que
j'avais pas été entièrement convaincu
par la façon dont cette réforme avait
été présenté mais je dis que le
président sur ce plan-là avait des à
trouver un ton qui était plus juste que
celui du gouvernement au cours des
derniers mois et deuxièmement je crois
qu'il a raison sur le plan
constitutionnel la réforme a été votée
il y a eu une motion de censure s'il y
avait pas eu de motion de censure il
faut rendre grâce à ceux qui ont déposé
la motion de censure sur ce plan il y
aurait pas eu de vote et ça ça aurait
été dramatique une réforme de cette
importance soit adoptée sans vote là il
y a eu un vote un vote étroit avec neuf
voix mais comme il a été rappelé la
République en 1875 a été voté à une voix
et personne ne s'en plaint personne ne
s'en plaint et deuxièmement le processus
continue je termine juste il a raison il
faut attendre le Conseil constitutionnel
je pense que le Conseil constitutionnel
va retoquer un certain nombre d'éléments
de cette de cette loi de ce projet de
loi je crois effectivement que
l'opposition à raison de dire que sur
certains plans il y a des ce qu'on
appelle des cavaliers législatives
c'est-à-dire des dispositions qui ne
devraient pas figurer dans une loi de
finances donc
l'index senior ou on verra ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel décidera mais il
me semble que le président a raison de
dire que force va demeurer à la loi que
ce processus se déroule régulièrement
que le 49-3 de toute manière et quelque
chose qui n'a rien de scandaleux qui a
été inventé d'ailleurs par Guy Mollet
pierre fimelin et en 1958 et donc
maintenant alors la seconde question qui
est tout à fait différente c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour l'avenir et là
il y a une grande déhéance quand on
atteint le degré de défiance de
l'opinion publique avec une une
expliquez on essaie de prendre un peu de
hauteur avec vous comment vous expliquer
qu'à l'issue de ces deux mois où tous
les jours les membres du gouvernement la
première ministre ont défendu ce texte
etc on en arrive à une opinion qui est
tellement contre ce texte qui n'arrive
absolument pas à être convaincu et même
si aujourd'hui le nombre de de personnes
qui pensent que la loi finira paraîtra à
adopter entre en vigueur et de plus en
plus grand
il reste 70% des Français
montrer archi quoi les Français sont
naturellement contre les réformes les
lois de réforme sur les retraites mais
là il se passe quelque chose et je vous
en donne volontiers actes avec regret
mais il se passe quelque chose de plus
profond et à mon avis c'est que le les
Français ne comprennent pas quel est le
projet fondamental du gouvernement pour
les années qui viennent je pense que
vous comprenez vous oui je crois je
comprends en tout cas ce qu'on a fait et
j'espère qu'on fera des choses
complémentaires je pense que il y a 5
ans Macron a été élu il a dit qu'il
fallait
relancer le système économique et
prendre les mesures parfois un populaire
très impopulaire pour relancer
l'économie et relancer l'emploi de ce
point de vue là on a eu un succès très
grand que on passe comme tous les succès
ça passe inaperçu mais la lutte pour
l'emploi a été très réussie c'est une
partie de de l'intraction qui a été bien
ressentie le second aspect de cette
action ça a été l'idée que l'avenir de
la France passait par l'Europe très bien
ça c'est fait et puis maintenant ce
depuis le second quinquennat on ne voit
plus on a été bloqué par le covid
déréglé par la guerre du crâne et on ne
voit plus comment reprendre l'effort et
l'effort à mon avis ce qui est ce qui
est à la base du mécontentement des
Français c'est que l'ensemble des
services publics pour des raisons très
complexes il ne s'agit pas de diaboliser
les uns ou les autres l'ensemble des
services publics ne délivre pas ce que
les Français attendent que ce soit
l'école la police la justice l'hôpital
etc et donc là il y a une un effort
immense de
reconstitution de l'appareil public qui
pourtant est à dispose beaucoup d'argent
et ça ça implique alors là un rapport
tout à fait différent au pouvoir et une
mobilisation de la base
ce matin pouvez-vous dire que
la parenthèse des retraites fermé fermer
le banc on passe à autre chose est-ce
que c'est ça
[Musique]
d'abord d'une façon générale je pense
qu'il y a énormément de choses à faire
quel était l'objet fondamental de cette
réforme l'objet fondamental de cette
réforme c'est de mettre les Français qui
ont plus de 60 ans en situation de
travailler dans des conditions décentes
productives pour le pays et compatible
avec leur état de santé bon et là il y a
immensé il y a énormément de choses
comme le dire ou de Baisieux d'ailleurs
il y a énormément de choses à faire pour
améliorer le travail des seniors pour
pour faire de l'ergonomie enfin
détailler
quand il s'est passé hier quand le
président de la République regrette que
les syndicats n'est pas présenté de
proposition de compromis sur le texte
soulignant que le gouvernement l'avait
fait avec le Parlement quand il attaque
la CFDT Laurent Berger contre Laurent
Berger lui répond déni et mensonge
Macron 2023 refait l'histoire
ment sur la sève d'été
où il en est où le pays le dialogue
social dans le dans le pays avec un
Laurent Berger avec un président qui
attaque nommément le patron de la CFDT
et l'autre qui lui répond la
confrontation a été vue elle a été vise
de part et d'autre quand même Laurent
Berger n'a pas ménagé le président de la
République tous mes amis qui sont
proches de la CFDT se sont quand même
inquietés de voir savoir comment Laurent
Berger pourrait sortir de cette affaire
parce que quand on est un syndicat
réformiste on respecte au bout du compte
on respecte et ça a été magnifiquement
conduit le mouvement était
magnifiquement conduit par Laurent
Berger mais on respecte l'autorité
politique en Allemagne par exemple les
syndicats ne vont tout simplement pas le
droit de manifester de protester dans
une affaire qui relève du bundestal qui
relève de l'autorité politique ça ne
vous comprenez l'organisme vous
comprenez la sortie d'Emmanuel Macron
hier sur la stabilité les syndicats je
me suis dit je n'aurais pas dit cela
mais vous savez je suis pas président de
la République je suis pas soumis au
stress auquel il est soumis et je crois
que c'est quand même anecdotique c'est
anecdot ensuite le la vraie question
c'est de savoir de quoi de quoi on va
parler maintenant et comment on renoue
le lien et là je crois avant de parler
au futur un mot tout de même au présent
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un climat est ruptif en
France les sondeurs spécialistes de
l'opinion qu'on a pu entendre à ce micro
disent qu'il y a de la colère de la
vertu du ressentiment que le pays est
traversé par ses passions là vous les
ressentez vous-même comment voulez-vous
ne pas les ressentir quand faire de
comment voulez-vous ne pas les ressentir
c'est absolument évident je le dis
depuis que vous m'interrogez là la
rupture morale entre une grande partie
de l'opinion et le pouvoir elle est là
donc il faut la traiter alors il faut
traiter il y a deux temps c'est ça que
j'essaie d'expliquer il y a le temps
immédiat qui est le temps de la légalité
nous avons après ça je trouve que le
président avait discours fort sur ce
plan-là il y a un processus
institutionnel il y a eu un vote
solennel qui a été fait dans de bonnes
conditions qui a été gagné deux peu par
la majorité la majorité au sens le plus
large du terme et qui a simplement
révélé à la fois l'étendue de
l'opposition et en même temps
l'incapacité des oppositions à former
une alternance parce qu'il y a aucune
bon il y a ça on attend le verdict du
Conseil est constitutionnel moi je crois
qu'il ne faut pas il faut respecter le
processus républicain et elle est
jusqu'au bout de cette affaire et
ensuite s'ouvre le grand chantier de la
reconstruction d'un lien fort entre le
pays et le pouvoir et ça à mon avis ça
passe pas simplement parce qu'on appelle
pudiquement un changement de
communication ou un changement de
méthode ça passe par véritablement une
mise à l'écoute et ce que j'ai proposé
c'est qu'on introduise dans ce pays des
techniques qui sont un peu empruntées à
ce que font nos amis allemands c'est à
dire une négociation
sûr pour les quatre années qui viennent
sur les grandes options les grandes
orientations gouvernementales qu'on veut
suivre et là on verra si dans le camp ce
que j'appelle le camp humaniste au sens
le plus large du terme à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a des gens qui sont prêts
à apporter leur leur pierre à cette
édifice mais ce qui ne marchera pas
c'est d'aller à la pêche aux voix
par voie sur différents sujets ça je
crois que cet empirisme là a trouvé ses
limites il a aussi dit une phrase qui a
été commentée Emmanuel Macron hier vous
vous avez dit tout à l'heure force doit
être à la loi lui il a dit on passe trop
par la loi dans notre République
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour la suite
du quinquennat qu'il faut gouverner
autrement par ordonnance en passant au
dessus du Parlement parce qu'on n'a pas
la majorité absolue
force est au procédures régulières mais
je suis tout à fait d'accord je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec la formule sur
le trop de loi moi je suis je j'ai été
très frappé tout au long du premier
de la droite est plus en position de
gagner que la gauche de la gauche et ça
moi en tant que humaniste universaliste
attaché à la raison aux droits à la
démocratie ça m'inquiète donc je crois
qu'il faut que nous retroussions nos
manches que nous changeons nos méthodes
que nous changeons notre approche et que
nous écoutions les gens discutions avec
eux si nous voulons nous sortir de ce
qui est un très mauvais pas actuellement
mais en même temps il faut tenir il faut
tenir bon sur la réforme actuelle parce
que sinon c'est vraiment l'État de droit
qui vole en éclat Jean-Luc l'ange ça
fait 6 ans qu'Emmanuel Macron est au
pouvoir il y a eu les gilets jaunes et
on a entendu ce que vous dites ce matin
il y a trois ans il faut changer la
méthode de gouvernement il faut
plus que la méthode oui oui mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que repenser la
relation du pouvoir et du peuple
repenser les méthodes de gouvernance
c'est des choses qu'on entend que
lui-même avait théorisé en 2017 en
arrivant il y a 6 ans en disant moi je
vais changer les choses on arrive 6 ans
après avez-vous l'impression si en 2017
il voulait renverser la table
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
l'impression on en est toujours à la
même il a fait le Conseil national de la
refondation il a tenté le grand débat
après le gilets jaunes et on en revient
toujours à cette fracture entre le
pouvoir et le peuple qui n'arrive qu'il
n'arrive pas à cautériser moi je ne
crois pas au renversement de table ça
jamais les gens disent faut tout changer
dans ce pays quand on dit il faut tout
changer ça veut dire qu'on il faut rien
changer en réalité il faut changer en
profondeur la fabrication de la décision
publique et Associés notamment on n'a
pas de majorité on n'a pas de majorité
absolue on ne fera pas et si ici le LR
et les autres ne veulent pas apporter
leur coopération ils en prendront aussi
la responsabilité devant le corps
électoral mais ce qui est ce qui est ce
qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que Macron
a été très bien réélu mieux réélu que
que tout le monde c'est ça qui a gardé
le Pen à 42% vous trouvez qu'il a été
très bien rééluia
c'est c'est quand même très grave que
que le
[Musique]
le fait de parler de dire des choses
vrai de dire des choses réfléchies ça
n'est plus créateur de légitimité on
vous dit vous défendez tel ou tel
intérêt vous n'êtes pas et on ne vous
écoute pas donc il y a une colère
profonde il y a un problème très profond
de de crise de la formation de crise de
l'école de non-apprentissage de ce
qu'est l'esprit critique tout un recul
de la raison du rationalisme à l'école
le si vous voulez quand on vous dit
maintenant ce qu'il faut le wokis etc il
faut dire quelqu'un qui parle vous lui
devez respect de la parole de ce qu'il
dit même si la tort non la vérité exige
que si la personne attend on lui dise je
ne pense pas comme vous et je trouve que
vous avez tort maintenant c'est c'est
presque c'est presque illégitime de dire
ça donc les bases du débat public sont
profondément profondément sapés
profondément corrodée actuellement et là
c'est la République du vide vous dites
on est dans la République du vide il y a
pas d'offre politique il y a rien
politique il y a ici il y a une offre
politique mais elle est pas suffisamment
elle est pas suffisamment perceptible et
je dis que on doit s'attaquer je l'ai
dit nous avons un énorme dossier qui est
dossier international ça passe par
l'Europe mais et là quand même c'est
géré très fortement par le Président de
la République qui a fait des choix très
bons sur l'Ukraine sur l'Europe il y a
sur le plan intérieur je vous dis le
grand problème c'est la pathologie la
relation pathologique de des services
publics et de la France et là ça
implique effectivement que tout le monde
se met en mouvement et là vous avez
quand même un front immobiliste qui est
très réel et qui s'agit de dégeler si je
puis dire les dans l'éducation nationale
partout vous avez des gens qui disent
non on veut pas trop changer on veut pas
développer trop d'autonomie pour les
établissements on ne veut pas établir
trop d'autorité enfin c'est très très
difficile
quelqu'un comme blanker c'était attaqué
à l'école sans doute avec un peu trop de
de de
rigidité à la fin mais il était porteur
de ça moi je crois si vous me demandiez
ce qu'il faut faire je crois qu'il faut
mettre plein feu sur tout ce qui relève
de l'éducation de la recherche de
l'intégration par l'école c'est quelque
chose qui permet de traiter le problème
des immigrés qui permet de traiter le
problème de l'ascenseur social qui
permet de traiter le problème de la du
défi technologique du pays suffisamment
depuis 6 ans Emmanuel Macron il le fait
suffisamment
c'est ça il faut mettre le plein feu
politiquement sur des choses qui soient
clairement perceptives par les Français
c'est ça le problème et pas toutes ces
lois auxquelles on comprend pas grand
chose en vérité allez on passe au
standard Jean-Marc nous appelle de
Bretagne bonjour Jean-Marc oui bonjour
je vous écoute d'accord c'est pas
vraiment une question c'est juste un
témoignage donc moi ça fait 40 ans que
je vote je ne suis jamais abstenu et pas
de problème à chaque fois j'y allais et
là c'est terminé depuis jeudi soir
depuis ce qui s'est passé jeudi soir
pour moi c'est terminé c'est un scandale
que jamais je n'oublierai voilà de quoi
vous parlez le 49 39 3 comme des
millions de personnes comme moi donc moi
je t'ai quelqu'un plutôt de calme voilà
je dirais et là j'ai je suis en rage
jamais jamais je n'oublierai ce qui
s'est passé jeudi soir et donc vous ne
voulez plus voter non c'est terminé je
pense que tous les tous les députés tous
les ministres qu'on cautionné ce qui
s'est passé sont maudit à tout jamais et
je pense que les gens n'oublieront
jamais ce qui s'est passé merci
Jean-Marc pour ce témoignage Jean-Louis
bourlonge comment augmenter le maudit va
vous répondre moi je suis
maudit je crois très franchement que
votre votre comportement qui est très
représentatif je ne nie pas du tout que
beaucoup de Françaises et de Français
pensent comme vous votre comportement à
mon avis présente deux de faiblesses la
première c'est par quoi vous remplacer
le
vous pouvez vous retirer de l'espace
public mais laisse pas public se retire
pas de vous donc de toute manière vous
aurez et si vous n'avez pas que les gens
qui sont sortis des œufs vous aurez des
gens qui sont sortis de jeûne CESU donc
il y a quand même un problème ça c'est
possible
retirer bien sûr mais je me place à du
point de vue de notre interlocuteur je
dis il faut c'est comme les gilets
jaunes vous ne pouvez pas dire je ne
veux pas et je ne dis pas ce que je veux
à la place donc ça c'est un problème et
sur le 49-3 je crois qu'il a été très
très mal compris il me paraît très
légitime très légitime ça a été c'est
une invention de guimoler un socialiste
ça a été utilisé innombrables fois par
Roca de grandes réformes comme la CSG
ont été adoptés par 49-3 c'est tout à
fait légitime qu'un gouvernement dise au
Parlement moi je propose quelque chose
c'est essentiel à mon action donc si
vous ne votez pas ça je m'en vais mais
en 2020 il est normal que et il est
normal qu'en 2023 ça passe peut-être
plus écoutez ça passe peut-être plus
mais il s'agit pas de savoir simplement
dans la vie ce qui passe et ce qui ne
passe pas il s'agit aussi de savoir ce
qui est légitime
qui a gouvernement Jean-Luc Bolland
est-ce qu'une est-ce que je sois est-ce
que le choix d'une mise au vote du texte
s'il avait décidé ce qu'il le souhaitait
si on doit croire Emmanuel Macron il
voulait pas le 49-3 il voulait mettre au
vote cette réforme essentielle prendre
le risque au fond de perdre sur de voies
mais mais mais mais mais mais prendre le
risque du vote est-ce que ça n'aurait
pas eu quelque chose de plus
démocratique
je vous suis qu'elle aurait été la
conséquence la conséquence logique de la
part de la première ministre et du
président de la République ça aurait été
la démission du gouvernement
une mise en cause or l'article 49-3 est
fait pour ça il est fait pour dire au
parlementaire prenez vos responsabilités
ce texte est un texte que à tort ou à
raison le gouvernement considère comme
essentiel à sa propre action si vous
votez contre vous le gouvernement
démissionnera et à ce moment-là le
président de la République soit et qui
leur est fait sans doute
nommera un autre Premier ministre soit
il prononcera la dissolution mais c'est
le jeu républicain le plus classique qui
soit et il ne faut pas je le dis à notre
ami qui vient de nous saisir il ne faut
pas bouder devant cette procédure c'est
une procédure logique de mise en
responsabilité du Parlement par le
gouvernement et du gouvernement par le
Parlement et d'ailleurs c'est Charles de
Courson quand il a présenté sa motion ça
a été un vote très clair ça a été à
votre éclair il y a eu énormément de
gens qui étaient contre parce que le
pays est hostile à cette réforme comment
le nier et mais les élus et pas par
plaisir vous imaginez bien que c'est pas
marrant pour les élus de défendre un
texte qui est aussi massivement rejeté
par l'opinion c'est parce que nous
considérons que ces conformes à
l'intérêt fondamental du pays que nous
prenons cette responsabilité d'ailleurs
tout le monde nous dit de toute manière
on vous attend au tournant et on vous
battra au prochain élections question de
Nicolas sur l'application d'un terme je
ne suis pas contre une réforme mais pas
pour qu'elle touche la classe moyenne
Jean-Louis bollange écoutez je crois
qu'elle ne touchait elle ne touchait pas
particulièrement la classe moyenne je
vous l'ai dit c'est cette réforme au
bout du compte quand on regarde
économiquement ça va se traduire par
quelques mois de plus de travail pour
l'ensemble de l'ensemble des salariés
français j'ai un peu la tendance à dire
tout ça pour ça je trouve qu'il y a un
excès dans les dénonciations de la
violence inouïe de la régression sociale
et là j'en veux un peu à Laurent Berger
d'avoir effectivement alimenté ce moulin
d'indignation sur une réforme qui est
quand même extrêmement mesurée qui fait
qu'on reste après la réforme l'un des
pays sinon pays d'Europe où on parle
plus tard à le plus tôt pardon à la
retraite borne elle peut rester au à
Matignon
c'est l'affaire du président de la
République dans décidé moi je trouve que
Isabelle borne a beaucoup de courage
beaucoup de de sens de la responsabilité
en revanche je trouve que la façon dont
cette réforme a été vendue aux français
malgré des ministres voulaient dire les
ministres ont été assez courageux mais
par le gouvernement dans son ensemble
atteint la fait de très beaux discours
du soft a fait très un très bon discours
si on pouvait l'entendre parce que dans
les hurlements c'était aussi ça qui a
caractérisé
ça ça ressort ce matin qu'Elizabeth
borne aurait dit en privé sur son
premier gouvernement je suis à la tête
d'un gouvernement à moitié composé de
débiles
je ne sais pas
si si elle pensait il faut qu'elle
démissionne
merci Jean-Louis bourlange d'avoir été à
notre micro ouais